I started and sold a software company
started and sold a gym licensing
business started and sold a suban
company and six other businesses over
the last 13 years the vast majority of
businesses that I talk to the
entrepreneurs think they're in one
business but they're actually in another
by only being able to solve one set of
problems they continue to jump from
business to business to business rather
than realize that there's one big
problem the business they're actually in
that unlocks all the Enterprise Value
that gets into the next level but if you
want to make a big business you want to
build an asset that to make you
generationally wealthy this is for you I
have made the mistake in almost every
business that I've been in in thinking I
was getting into one business when in
reality I was getting into a very
different business and discovering the
real business that you're actually in is
what will unlock the amount of growth
and money-making that you really want to
get into It's usually the second and
third level of Entrepreneurship within
whatever opportunity vehicle you're
pursuing so let me give you example to
kind of make this real when I got into
the gym business I liked Fitness and so
I thought that the business was going to
be about like macros and results and
workouts and all of that that's what I
thought the business was going to be
about uh but once I got into the
business I realized it was actually just
about marketing and sales that specific
business is about marketing and sales
overall now when I make these
generalizations all businesses are like
cars like if you don't have wheels the
car is not going to move if you don't
gas the car is not going to move if you
don't have an engine the car is not
going to move but the question is what
is the biggest limit or what's the
biggest thing that gives you the most
return in that specific vehicle or that
specific business and so I'm going to
walk you through four or five different
businesses that I've been what I thought
it was versus what it really was and
then I'll turn it back to you and
thinking about how you can apply that
same methodology and I'll bet you many
of you and I get this because I have a
lot of conversations with business
owners today they don't know what
business they're really in all right so
I thought it was about Fitness but it
was actually about sales and marketing
if you look at the biggest Fitness
companies in the world like especially
in the gym space they acquisition
machines that's what they are very very
good at the actual fitness component of
it is actually pretty minor right and I
mean I'll tell you this from talking to
the franchisors who in many many many
locations or privately owned ones have
thousand plus locations that the fitness
stuff is almost an afterthought they're
like yeah yeah yeah get people to sweat
move around whatever because the reality
is that within Fitness for example the
biggest problem is that people don't
show up because of other reasons and so
you have to always go get more customers
the good news is is that everyone's
trying to lose weight three times a year
and so there are plenty of people so
that was the first business that I
misunderstood what business I was really
in now thankfully quickly I learned that
and then that became the skill set that
I you know doubled down on now with that
I then was like okay well I'm going to
start a sub company which which with
Prestige Labs now again I thought that
business was going to be all about the
product I thought it was all going to be
about the stuff that's inside of it and
so I got Dr cashy my good friend who's
bi he's a PhD biochemist one of the
smartest human beings on Earth and I
said hey man can you make the best
products I said make a sandwich you
would actually eat because he he made
all these o things for Olympians and he
would put together these trash bags full
of like specific ingredients and
specific compounds and he's like dude
these are going to be way too expensive
like it's not going to be commercially
viable based on the quality of the
ingredients and I was like dude just
make the best product I'll figure out
how to sell it and so um that's that was
the focus that I had in Prestige lives
but guess what once I got into that
business I realized that it actually had
very little to do with what was in the
bottle because basically anything
anything that's in a bottle that you
don't taste the inside the vast majority
of products that are out there benefit
off of plus sibo and no sibo effect
basically people taking something and
then they feel better because they take
something and I want to be I want to be
clear Placebo effects a real effect so
like I'm about the effect whatever works
for you works for you and that's not
really the point of this talk but more
so that I got into the business thinking
that what was inside the bottle was the
thing that mattered but the reality was
what was on the outside of thing the
bottle and the thing that the bottle was
next to meaning it became what I
realized almost too late was that it's
it's a business that's based on on brand
it's based on branding and it's based on
media in terms of having tons and tons
of traffic and so I thought I was
building a product based company that
was going to be based on what's inside
the bottle when everything that was
limiting the business what was on the
outside of the bottle and I saw the guys
who are the biggest in the space and
this is the little Telltale sign by the
way if you want to hack this is you look
at the people who are the biggest in
your space so take your model take it to
its natural extreme and look and I think
there's a lot of wisdom that can be
found from that and trying to reverse
engineer like what are the things that
make this different now you might be
like and here's this is what I used to
do all right so like don't make this
mistake when I was in the gym industry I
would look like when I started I was
like oh my God I can make way better
workouts than those guys that's because
those guys don't give a [__] about their
workouts because that's not the main
thing in the business I got into the sub
business like oh my God I like these
guys are making hundreds of millions of
dollars on this product that's just
mediocre like the thing is is that most
of the customers that are buying it
don't even know the difference anyways
which means that your differentiator
isn't actually making you different
you're the only one who knows your
differentiator which is not good your
customer has realize what the
differentiator is and so the thing is is
that for most supplements the
differentiator is LeBron takes it or so
and so takes it or I think this is cool
or my friend Sally likes it right or and
I'll be clear on a consumables
perspective if it has a flavor then the
flavor becomes very important in the
long run in terms of how good it tastes
because most people take ag1 because
they think it tastes good and because
they feel good about it not because
what's inside of it all right so just to
be clear I got into the gym business and
I thought it was about Fitness but is
really about marketing and sales I got
in in into Prestige Labs of sub business
and I thought it was about the stuff
inside the bottom when really about
brand and building a big media traffic
machine and then I was like okay I think
I'm getting the hang of this of just
making mistakes over and over again so
then I got into the software business
and I was like okay I get it everything
is about marketing and sales I'll be
able to sell the [__] out of this and
guess what we sure as hell could because
I knew how to Market and sell and so
then I got into the software software
business and I realized by the way side
note software tends to sell itself you
know why because if you can have
technology and say hey there's that
thing that you're doing that this will
do automat atically not a very hard
pitch but the problem with software is
actually delivering on the promise and
so it actually is a very product driven
business because anyone can sell it the
constraint like software is not that
difficult to sell at least this is my
experience with this all right so take
that with my big Himalayan size gra of
salt for me that's when I realized that
product was the main thing and guess
what I don't when I started out I
outsourced the product I had an
Outsource Dev team make the product for
me which I then realized was the core
part of the business it's like starting
a s company then try to have an agency
build your sub company for you if you're
in the sub business or you're in the
consumer product goods business
Outsourcing acquisition Outsourcing
brand Outsourcing media is like it's
it's that's the business like that's the
business you're in it's not the stuff
inside the bottle all right so I'll give
you another one
so I had a gym owner uh friend of mine
from many many years ago he was in he
was in he he became a Gard he was a ly
awesome guy and he started um he had a
couple locations and his wife started a
cleaning business because they got into
airbnbs because you started making money
in the gym so you started investing and
he realized he actually liked real
estate better than you lik the gyms
which is awesome great um and so they
started a cleaning company to uh clean
houses for the airbnbs but then they
realized they got in the Airbnb
community and they also got in just like
that area and they're like you know what
we could probably just sell cleaning to
other people and so this was interesting
I had dinner with him and he was saying
I was like so what's your LTV to CAC
he's like oh dude cac's like $25 and I
was like what he's like oh getting
customers in cleaning not a problem and
this is and he was like this is so
different from the gym business because
the gym business getting the customers
getting have to arm wrestle suie for an
hour to get her to say yeah she's going
to stop eating crap and start coming to
the gym three times a week but if you
just say hey I'm going to clean your
stuff and you don't have to do anything
not a very hard sale and so he said the
real problem that I'm having right now
is actually getting people to do the
cleaning right is actually getting hot
you know people who speak English who
don't steal who show up on time and do
all that and like do a good job
consistently he the problem that's
actually the problem of the business and
so I had this it was this great moment
for me because I love seeing finding
found finding out what is the real
business behind the business and so if
you're in the cleaning business you're
not in the cleaning business you're in
the recruiting and training business you
have to learn how to get low skill labor
in high volume to show up for you
consistently which is a cultural thing
it's a training thing and part of that
has to do with brand but a lot of it is
just having the incentive system
structured such that that type of person
can still succeed and he had a cool
little thing that he did he did he had a
setup where they got paid not by hour
but by clean and so they were actually
incentivized and so basically and this
by the way big Pro tip on business is
you want to have paired incentives so
it's like having quality and speed and
so it's like if you have a customer
support team you want to measure them
not just on like percentage of tickets
that are absolutely resolved you also
want to have speed of completion if you
only have one then you have lots of
people responding as quickly as possible
but not getting it done and on the flip
side if you just do on rather the ticket
is completely resolved people won't move
fast enough and so it's having paired
metrics um Andy gr talks about this in
high output management really good book
If you ever like want to learn more
about Ops pretty high level though just
to be really honest with you but it's a
great book any and so the paired meure
for him was you get you can clean as
many houses as you can in a day and I
pay you per clean and so that drove up
his productivity per employee and so the
paired metric was that if you don't do a
good job you have to go back and do it
again at no cost and so that was the
deal and that was also part of his offer
for the cleaning thing and it worked
really great and so like if you don't
think we do a good job we'll come back
and clean your whole house again and
we'll do it for free and so that was the
paired metric again so he thought he was
getting the acquisition business he's
like dude I can get customers all day
long in this business and he it's
because he came from the gym world and
expected it to be the same and so I've
noticed this is this continued thing is
that what I think I'm getting into is
actually not the real constraint of the
business and I'm going to I want to Leap
Frog ahead here but like this is a
little bit of foreshadowing for the
woman in the red dress all right so I'll
just I'll just leave that there all
right so I'll give you one for the
anybody who's in like the Consulting
space or Professional Services space if
you sell to businesses you sell how to
Market how to I mean even accounting you
sell lawyer stuff you do Consulting in
general any of that stuff you think that
you're in the marketing and sales
business because that's what people will
tell you right but if you really want to
play this game at a high level now again
it's a car if you have no Marketing
sales you're not going to have a
business right duh but which is these
things is the thing that unlocks the
biggest level of growth is actually
again look at the biggest companies in
the space you look at ey eron young you
look at KPMG you look at you look at uh
McKenzie you look at Bane you look at
BCG these big public massive firms
multi-billion dollar hundred billion
dollar companies what is what is the
thing what is the business they're
really in they're in the recruiting
business as well and specifically the
talent management business because
different than the cleaning business now
structurally it's recruiting for sure
but it's at a completely different level
they're trying to skim the cream of the
crop because how do you scale expertise
their Intelligence on demand if you go
to the bet you go to pulson you go to
some big big Law Firm right in Manhattan
right some big law firm with a Manhattan
address they have to attract the
absolute best and brightest people
otherwise the brand will degrade over
time but how do you attract the best and
brightest people well that's why a lot
of these Professional Services
businesses are based on Partnerships
they're limited Partnerships they're
llps all right and so it's because
anybody they have a track for eventually
becoming an owner in the business and
most service-based businesses that rely
on
expertise have tracks for people to have
small slices of ownership and they're
willing to have a small slice of a $200
billion pie rather than start out on
their own and they also have sub
Specialties underneath of that you're a
IP lawyer you're a you're a you know
defense lawyer whatever they' have all
these different you know subtracks
underneath of that and so again you get
into the Consulting business and people
say hey it's about marketing and sales
but really if you want to scale and and
again this is the thing if you want to
scale if you just want to make money
then sure just market and sell and and
you can make a buck right that's not the
problem but if you want to get big you
want to build an asset the business you
get in there is on talent and how do you
retain talent and how do you improve the
value of that talent and make them look
because otherwise what do you do what
what happens if you do a great job with
talent in that business but you don't
retain them they take up they take your
customers and they leave they start
their own shop they hang their own
shindle up that's that's the game there
right so the G the the figure what you
have to figure fure out this is the big
billion dollar problem is what you have
to do all right now um I I I'll leave it
at that because I think I made the point
now here here's why this is important is
that if you know the business that
you're really in you actually can get
paid to solve the right problem all
right now the way that I like to think
about this is that like as entrepreneurs
we get paid to solve problems and the
bigger the problem the bigger the payoff
and so I like to imagine it like I've
got I've got this big massive wall in
front of me and the thing is is I see
the wall but I don't know how thick it
is but I but I have an idea that it's
pretty thick right cuz I'm like shoot I
don't know I'm going to get through this
wall but I like to mentally envision
myself that there's this big pile of
money on the other side and I remember
having this conversation with a
portfolio company we're like hey we
think that we need to build software
into this business and actually
transform this business from a media
company into a software company and it's
like this is a big strategic bet like
lot of resources a lot of time basically
a lot of like lost growth like instead
of us gassing it on this side we're
actually going to basically maintain
here and then deploy a lot of resources
into growing software Ware and so I was
talking to the founder he was like this
is really hard this is going to be
really really hard for us to do and I
was like yeah yeah it's going to be
really hard I said but um if we solve it
we get an extra $250 million so does
that feel worth it and he was like well
when you say it like that and I was like
right so for 250 million bucks would I
solve it yeah it feels it feels a lot
more uh approachable or at least it
feels worth it and so I'd encourage you
to think like what is the ultimate price
tag of me solving this problem worth and
then all of a sudden you're like okay
then you can actually appropriately
allocate your personal resources to
solving the problem because it really
will make you a lot of money now
um a lot of times we need to frame the
problem for what we get by solving it
otherwise we avoid solving it um and so
knowing the business that you're really
in isn't really what you think it is
it's often the second or third order
effect and that's the big wall and so
you come in like my friend did he starts
acquiring customers he's like I'm going
to make so much money here and he's like
oh shoot I got to hire in staff people
boom he sees this big wall and he's like
oh I'm not equipped to solve this
problem and this here it is this is the
meat this is the part that I've been
waiting to get you and Hammer you guys
on is hey and if you'd like to get
personalized advice on how to scale your
business and unlock the Enterprise Value
kind of like the stuff that we're
talking about here today acquisition.
comom just started its new workshop
division uh where we we host one or two
days a month uh at our headquarters here
in Vegas for businesses that we're not
necessarily invested in nor do you have
to become a portfolio company but it's a
way for us to meet more companies for
you to meet us for us to help you solve
some problems unlock some big value if
that sounds a little interesting go to
acquisition. comom hit the scaling
button and our team will see if you
qualify hope to see you soon the woman
in the red dress appears now as soon as
you realize the business you're really
in and you also realize that you're not
equipped to solve it because you don't
know what the hell you're doing and you
don't know what you got into to begin
with that is when the woman in the red
dress appears now if you don't know if
you're not familiar with my stuff the
woman of the red dress is any shiny
object it's the distraction and the
interesting thing about the woman of the
red dress is that the better you get at
business the hotter she is and so like
you think you can you learn to say no to
a two out of 10 yeah because you've got
some crackhead lady on the side of the
street it's like okay she's like hey
let's go home and you're like I'm good
I'd rather just not get chlamydia
whatever you've got right um and so all
businesses have [__] they all have [__]
they all have a big brick wall that you
have to come in contact with and guess
what that's why you get paid to solve
the [__] problem that's why you make
outsized returns is because you have to
be willing to confront with the
sledgehammer in hand not knowing how
thick the wall is going to be and start
hammering away at it with the hope that
when you get to the other side it will
have been worth it and often it is now I
want to I want to drive this point home
so if you have a roofing business if you
have a restaurant business if you have a
dry clean cleaning business all you have
to do is look at the world and see is
there any version of this business that
is a billion dollar company or even a
hundred million dollar company whatever
your goals are and most times you'll
find that there is that but you'll also
find that it just takes time to get
there because the ount times I have
let's let's say small business own this
actually happens a lot right is hey I've
got a I've got a a roofing contracting
business okay cool and they say hey
should I jump into a different
opportunity vehicle I'm like okay what
are you doing they're like I'm doing 4
million Top Line I'm doing a million
bucks in bottom line okay okay okay well
why why don't you just 10x the size of
your company ah and then they say well
I've got this big concrete wall in front
of me right what they describe next is
the real problem of that business the
business that they're really in that
they didn't know they were getting into
and I want to be clear this only happens
at scale all right so once like all
businesses like if you're if you're if
if you're new to entrepreneurship you
got to figure out the basics of
everything you got to figure out that a
wheel is round you got to make sure that
gasoline is combustible you got to make
sure that there's some sort of engine it
might be a sewing machine in the
beginning that's that's powering your
car it might be a remote control car
that that can only go you know 10 miles
an hour but like there's got to be some
engine otherwise you're not going to get
any movement right but when you start
really wanting to achieve scale there's
going to be a big hairy problem there's
going to be a big concrete wall in front
of you that you don't know how thick it
is
and that is the work that is where the
Enterprise Value is unlocked and the
vast majority of the time when we're
investing in a company or we take over a
company we are just comfortable with the
fact that there's a concrete wall and
we're just going to chip away at it and
so a lot of the work that I do is
actually expectation management with the
team is saying yeah this is going to
take two years yeah this will take three
years and they're like wait three years
I'm like yeah well I'm in this F like I
mean let me put it this way if in five
years we had $100 million Enterprise to
this business is it worth it they're
like well yeah I'm like do you think we
can solve it in five years I'm like well
yeah but then guess what they don't
do be willing to wait 5 years and so the
thing is is that sometimes it takes
somebody from the outside say like dude
let's Zoom all the way out if you solve
this for 10000 million bucks is it worth
it yeah okay well it's going to take
that long oh huh and then things start
to settle and then you get this you get
less frenetic energy the amount of
wasted effort for entrepreneurs that
goes into this ideation of what else
they could be doing with their time or
with their skill sets honestly it's it's
like oh great analogy it's like it's
like being single versus being married
all right hear me out is that when
you're single at least for me when I was
guy I would say 30% of my time was or
I'm being generous maybe 40% of my time
might have been higher anyways I'm not
going to into it was allocated to like
the idea of chasing tail so it was like
man what if what if that worked out what
if that worked out and I'm I'm I'm I'm
spinning multiple plates I'm I'm doing
lead nurture right I'm working the
pipeline I'm planting seeds I'm I'm
making a a quippy comment I'm responding
to a story whatever and so I'm working
leads and so as I was doing this right
all my attention was going to
possibility was to potential was to what
if right as soon as I got married the
thing the biggest gift that marriage got
me was it got me 30 to 40% of my time
back was I didn't have to think about
this like this part of my life was not
done but like solved as in like I'm
goingon to be with Ila cool great now
all the extra tension that used to go to
like possibility in terms of what who of
who else could be goes back into the
main thing which for me was business now
within the business it works the same
way is that I think most of you guys are
dating your business but you need to get
married to your business you guys are
trying to have friends with benefits
with your business trying to go on dates
maybe date a couple other business on
the side have some side chicks and then
you're wondering why your relationship
with your business isn't that healthy if
you go all in on the business the
business will go all in on you and I
promise you it's just that the guy who's
beating you right now he's just
committed he's just married he's just
married to the business he's like I'm I
mean if it takes me 5 years it takes me
5 years but like where am I going like
I'm in this I'm in it for the long
and he sees what the value of a 30-year
marriage would be or a 50-year marriage
would be with his business and so if you
know the business you're really in which
you usually find out a couple years into
the business which is once you solve the
basics of business you realize oh this
is the big hairy problem and then you
don't know how long it will last but I
promise you that someone else has solved
it and I promise you that they weren't
super Geniuses they just were willing to
commit they were willing to to swing the
hammer at the wall for a very long
period of time and willing to zoom out
and say I can think in fiveyear in
commence and do I think that if I put
everything I have and not get distracted
with the woman in the red dress not have
the side chick not have these these
other businesses I'm flirting with that
I'm keeping warm on the side these
networking lunches for this guy I might
do a partnership with even though it has
nothing to do with this business because
he says hey you're good at this I'm good
at this we could do this thing together
none of that and just being like no I'm
just I'm just going to keep slamming at
this wall because if if I just get this
one thing right if I just break through
this wall I will unlock all of the
wealth that I've ever wanted but there
is a big thick massive gray boring wall
between there and where you want to go
and it's just who's willing to keep
swinging the hammer for a long period of
time without getting distracted and
without thinking they're smarter than
they are keep being awesome [__] slay
love you all bye